is incompetence is hitting border
communities the hardest just look at
arizona's tucson sector they've seen a
44 increase in illegal migrants crossing
the past year alone my next guest is
fighting for a chance to represent
arizona jim lemoen is a republican
arizona senate candidate and he joins me
now jim good to see you
so talk to me about uh illegal
immigration and the impact it's having
on voters in arizona because as we know
arizona used to be a a red state but joe
biden won it in 2020 so how does this
impact the way the vote goes in arizona
sean it is front and center it is the
number one issue in arizona 72 percent
of republicans and the independents who
vote in the primary and general say this
is their number one issue it's going to
manifest itself all across our state you
know we're front and center here with
this 50 000 per week invasion of our
country now i is your ex-military as a
business guy who gets things done came
from a career building large-scale power
plants billion dollar plants own time of
budget i intend to do everything in my
power sean to shut down business in u.s
senate until we get this resolved get
back to remaining mexican policy ensure
that is the law of the land and in fact
in force because
this invasion in arizona sean it's it's
unbelievable i mean i served in the
military to stop invasions of other
countries and it's happening here
so so jim you want to replace senator
kelly um we've heard the national
polling with the hispanic vote they have
an approval rating for joe biden of 24
the lowest of any category in the
country they have the lowest for joe
biden and so are you seeing that
movement with hispanics
in texas that say listen i'm sick of
these policies i don't want open borders
i want you to focus on a great economy
are you picking that up as you're
traveling the state
sean absolutely and we're advertising in
english and in spanish all across the
southern part of our state we've been
well received in the communities you
know these are devastated along the
border the cartel controls the border
here in arizona sixty two hundred and
fifty dollars per person is paid for
every migrant coming across that border
so yes in those advertisements in some
cases they found excuses before these
radio stations not to allow republican
in we're there we're being well received
the mining community also those type of
communities are looking for jobs and i
intend to bring mining back strongly
here in arizona it's finally time for
someone in in washington sean to
actually stand up
have the guts to get things done for the
american people the people right here in
arizona who on the front lines of this
craziness and that's why as a business
guy i've stepped up not a lawyer we
don't need any more of those in dc we
see how they failed us but i'll stand up
for the people out here and i'll take it
to the hill
and i'll make sure that as a army
veteran that our people in arizona are
taken care of jim and i ran for congress
i never said i was a lawyer i always
said i was a prosecutor
no one likes lawyers listen good luck
with the race i know how hard they are
and happy fourth of july
happy fourth and god bless america hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else